Speaker 1: ans have representing them. This is
the ideology that we see really, really tragic,
sad stuff. Yet another Donald Trump address now
appears to be almost certain this summer. Let
me explain that. We've been seeing some of this
news for a bit now. It now seems pretty clear.
Vice News reports Trump's next criminal charges
practically on the calendar. Let me explain.
Former. This is from the article. Former President
Donald Trump's second criminal indictment looks
all but certain to go down this summer. You could
even market on your calendar between June 11, I'm
sorry, July 11 and September 1st. Why those dates?
Because Fulton County District Attorney Fani
Willis, Fanni Willis, no matter how I pronounce
it, someone writes to me saying I'm saying it
wrong. Fannie Willis has formally asked local
officials to beef up security during that window
when she plans to announce charging decisions in
her long running investigation of Trump's attempt
to reverse his 2020 election defeat in Georgia.
She wouldn't need all that extra security if she
weren't planning to go after Trump himself. Former
prosecutors and legal experts say Titus Nichols,
an Atlanta area defense attorney and former
prosecutor, said, quote, The Fulton DA's letter
makes it almost certain that Trump is getting
indicted. There is no reason to send something
in writing, no other reason to the sheriff.
So let me tell you what this is all about.
Several weeks ago, Fannie Willis's office
did send a letter to the sheriff. Indicating
requesting additional security during this next
period that will contain whatever decisions are
made with regard to Trump and Georgia. That period
of time is July 11 to September one. And as former
prosecutors, lawyers, others are saying, it is
just casual observers of this are saying, why
would she make that request were it not because
there is going to be a decision made to arrest
Donald Trump and that there is going to be a
similar circumstance that plays out in Georgia as
what we saw in New York City. I think that that's
pretty likely. You know, if we want to make a sort
of differential diagnosis of the facts, you could
say, well, in order to not show her hand early,
she is requesting the extra security, regardless
on the idea that there might be agitated people,
whether or not Trump is charged or something
along those lines. Maybe, like maybe she says,
well, if I charged Trump, his supporters will be
furious and they might show up and be violent. And
if I announce I'm not charging Trump, people who
want him charged will show up and be violent. The
reason that's hard to believe is we've seen no
evidence. There's no reason to believe or fear
that people who think Trump should be charged
are going to show up and be violent if he isn't
charged. We just I just don't there's no reason
to think that that would happen. So I do think
the most likely scenario is Trump is going
to be charged in Georgia. This is not going
to impact his existing supporters very much in all
likelihood. The question is, is it going to impact
Trump's ability to be out and campaigning if now
with another arrest, another indictment, another
pending trial, if this all starts to get in the
way of Trump being able to just go and campaign?
It may start to make him an unappealing candidate.
The counterpoint to that is there absolutely are
MAGA people on the right on the Republican in
the Republican voting rolls who will actually
be energized if Trump is arrested again. They
will feel that he is being scapegoated. They will
feel that he is being you know, and remember,
the key word is feel. They will feel that he
is being targeted for political reasons rather
than he did things no former president has ever,
ever, ever done. The Georgia case in particular
is interesting because it is arguably where the
the most serious and most relevant charges
may come from. And there are other prominent
Republicans that are wrapped up entangled in
the Georgia mess, Lindsey Graham and so many
others. It is not yet clear even whether or not
Trump is charged and it looks like he will be.
That may not be the full list. There may be even
more. Republicans charge the fake elector scheme
required dozens of highly placed people. So
this could actually be a major, major take
down of a number of conservative figures speaking
legally, of course. And as always, you all know,
I'm for law and order and I actually am for
law and order. If there is no evidence against
someone, they should not be charged. I don't
want anybody charged for political reasons,
reasons of retribution, revenge, or whatever
the case may be. If there is no evidence,
then do not charge people. What I want is for
the justice system and for the investigations
to happen unfettered, unconstrained by political
meddling or whatever the case may be. Look at the
evidence, compare it to the laws, and then make
a charging decision that should apply to Trump.
It should apply to Biden, Joe Biden,
Hillary, Obama, People who work locally,
people who dog walkers, McDonald's employees.
This should be the standard that is always
applied. And I am consistently for that. So
the news is almost certainly Trump's getting
arrested again. If and when it happens, we will
have it for you. It is the Friday show in the
sense that it's Friday and this is the show. We
will take a very quick break and continue right
after this. The David Pakman Show continues to be
an audience supported program. What that means is
there's no major corporate funder of our show that
comes with a lot of great benefits, including that
I just decide what's on the show and no one
can coerce me or convince me to talk or not
talk about whatever the downside is. We do depend
on your support to do what we do, but we have a
great system for that called membership.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
It takes mere seconds and you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now. If you'd like
to get a discount off of the cost of your
membership, sign up at join Packman dot com.